the greatest gap in the world between
successful and unsuccessful people
is the thinking gap i think great
entrepreneurs
must have the curiosity to to
kind of metaphorically see around the
corner the worst
tragedy of man kind almost any
individual
is that they're attached to opinions
that are wrong
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how
successful people think enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one clear the weeds with louise hay
i've come to realize it boils down to
choosing the thoughts you think
and choosing the foods you eat and when
you can be
wise in both areas you have perfect
health
because the body knows how to take care
of itself
but not if you give it a lot of junk and
not if you give yourself a lot of junk
thoughts so it's it's a clearing it's
clearing the weeds
from the area from the mind and from the
soil you see
life loves you life really loves you but
if you don't love yourself
it's very hard for life to bring you the
goodies
because you've got this wall up so when
you can learn to love
who you are and that's the way you were
born when you were a little tiny baby
and when i say you
i mean everybody listening to this uh we
all
adored ourselves we loved our bodies we
loved every part of ourselves
and then we started to listen to other
people who told us we weren't good
enough
or we didn't do it right or no no no
and so we decided that maybe we weren't
very good
and that's where we get all mixed up but
when we can get back to that point of
just
adoring this marvelous critter in here
uh then life says oh they've she's got
it she's got it
let's give her goodies and then the next
step is to be very grateful about it
yes when you're really grateful then
they want to give you
more rule number two change your
approach with brendan burchard
most of success is just about how we use
our psychology
i remember when i was going to start my
business and i i
really wanted to be good at it you know
i was trying to become an author and a
speaker and do these types of videos and
do some online training for people on
the topics of motivation
and marketing and you know some all
these people are saying well brendan
you know you may or may not be
successful with that you're you know
blah blah and i thought
it's a weird thing it's not like there's
a trait of successful people you look
across
history and successful people it's not
they're not from a given background
they don't come from a specific economic
stature they're not in a position where
you know they're one demographic or
another democrat i mean it's all over
i mean we've got thousands of collective
years of history people succeed
some people do some people don't and i
think it more comes down to
how do we manage our mind and how do we
manage our days
and i think that there's a difference
between successful people and
unsuccessful people in the way they
particularly think about
um approaching something new you know i
think unsuccessful people
when they have a big dream and they
start thinking about what's going to be
required
to accomplish that dream they get very
limiting in their beliefs about
themselves and what's possible
and specifically they say three types of
things you know the first thing they
often say is well
you know i don't know how to do that so
they stop
they say you know i i don't have those
things
so they stop or they say i don't know
you know i'm not like those people i'm
not like that
and so they stop but successful people
have a different way the same thing
everybody dreams you dream i dream
successful people dream people just
starting out everybody dreams
everyone has a vision everyone if they
can just take five minutes today and
think about
their lives we could all come up with
ways to improve our lives and reach
another
level of success joy happiness
achievement contribution
fulfillment soul you know we can all
elevate
but the challenge is that the
unsuccessful people they keep stopping
when they think of what they currently
know have
or are but successful people say well i
want to do that
but i don't know how to do that but
instead of stopping they say well then
my job is to go learn that
they take their current limitation and
they put it on their agenda
as a job to do as a thing to figure out
a thing to make happen
instead of saying well i don't have that
they say well then my
job is to go build that or i'm not like
that then they say well then my job is
to go
become more of that become that person
who could accomplish those things
all right my friend evan carmichael's
book listen humans are built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
rule number three think differently with
john maxwell
how a person thinks is going to
determine
almost everything about his or her
success in fact here's what i say doug
to you and to
all of my friends when i teach about
success i
think the greatest gap in the world
between successful and unsuccessful
people
is the thinking gap i think successful
people
think differently not better maybe even
not smarter
but differently than unsuccessful people
i have never known a person who was a
life coach
a leader a successful person at all that
didn't
understand the power of thinking that's
why doug
every day in the morning i look at my
schedule
and i think and ask myself this question
what's the most important person i want
to see what's the most important event
i'm going to see and then participate in
because i want to make sure that i
maximize my day in the evening
i reflect and i say okay how did my day
go and i go through my whole
hour-by-hour calendar why
because here's what i know if we go
through
our day without thinking we will go
through our
out our day without being successful and
sowing the seeds that we need
that can reap the harvest that only a
good mindset
can bring to us rule number four change
your thoughts
with grant cardone one of the key things
one of the things that's made me
successful in my life
is making it a priority to control
my thoughts like what what am i thinking
about like literally
putting discipline in on how i talk to
myself
you got to change you got to change the
way you think
and a way to change the way you think
ultimately there's two ways
okay i mean there's probably three or
four ways but
first of all the one way is to start
discipline yourself catch yourself every
time you say
i don't have time say hey i create time
every time you say i don't have money i
create money
um or maybe just start just start
literally like talking to yourself that
hey i am a millionaire i am a
multi-millionaire
rule number five see around the corner
with howard schultz
i think great entrepreneurs must have
the curiosity
to to kind of metaphorically see around
the corner
what's coming what can i anticipate that
other people
don't see and then
you must have the courage of your
convictions
to execute the strategy rule number six
do your gift
10 acts with steve harvey the only
difference between successful people or
not
is just how they think rich people think
different
quit letting people tell you you got to
get qualified in another program
you don't need another program to be
successful you need to change the way
you think
so here's the deal
the problem with becoming a millionaire
is that when you decide that you want to
be a millionaire
you immediately start thinking how can i
become a millionaire
well that thought don't just pop into
your head
so you get frustrated and you don't
become a millionaire
and you start creating stuff like well i
guess this wasn't the lord's will
as soon as i think of how i'm gonna make
a million you can't think of how to make
a million dollars
stop do you know if you know how to make
a million dollars what's the date
tuesday
when you make it by friday would not you
make it by friday
but suppose i told you how you can
become a millionaire
with what you have because here's the
deal
all of you have everything it takes to
become rich
you just don't believe it now if you can
develop this theory that i'm about to
share with you
i have the way for you to be rich this
is it
first of all all of you have a gift
god gave it to you when he created you
god never created a single soul without
giving him a gift
that's the god that created you he's a
very smart god
here the cold thing when he made you he
put the gift inside of you
he didn't hide it under the ocean it
ain't on the mountain nowhere
it ain't under no rocks you ain't got to
go drill it god
put what you needed inside of you at
birth
all of you have a gift but you have got
to do your
gift the thing god gave you at birth to
do
it is the thing that you do the absolute
best with the least amount of effort
that's your gift anything else you doing
you wasting your time
do you hear me you wasting your time
if when the alarm clock goes off in the
morning and it makes you
sick every morning that that alarm go
off it's cause you ain't doing your gift
you're going against what god created
you to be
do do most of you know what your gift is
who in here doesn't know their gift yet
okay let me tell you what you do go home
today
don't talk to nobody sit down and have
one conversation with yourself
what is the thing that i do the absolute
best
with the least amount of effort this
ain't going to take you long
you old enough you grown write it down i
don't care if it's networking
i don't care if it's babysitting i don't
care if it's doing
color i don't care if it's painting
whatever it is
it's what you do sing it whatever you do
the best write it down that's your gift
that's it you ain't got to go asking a
bunch of people
they've been telling you your whole life
you know you ever have
people call you with a problems they
always call you with your problems cause
you gifted at it
but you didn't you didn't know how to
identify if you identify your gift
now let me ask you this question this
thing that you're gifted at
if you did it for somebody do you think
somebody
would pay you ten dollars for your gift
just ten dollars
could you babysit for ten dollars could
you cut somebody's hair for ten dollars
could you cut their grass for ten
dollars could you make them a chicken
dinner for ten dollars
could you could you could you do
something for tinder
everybody don't you have something
somebody would give you ten dollars for
okay now once you have something that
somebody's willing to pay you ten
dollars for
this is how this work it's called the
multiples of 10.
see you don't have to figure out how to
be a millionaire you just got to figure
out the thing that makes you
ten dollars so now here we go you do it
and you make ten dollars
as soon as they pay you the 10 go do it
10 more times
whatever it was watch some more kids 10
more times
get another 10. you got 100 when you get
100
whatever you did to make that 100 listen
to me do it 10 more times
you ain't got to get tricky with it just
do it 10 more times
you'd have made a thousand dollars
whatever you did to make the thousand
dollars
don't get smart stay stupid now do it
ten more times
you have now made ten thousand dollars
hold up
now we finna grow a little bit but guess
what you gotta do to grow
you just gotta do some mold and rule
number seven the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is be open-minded with ray dalia
but what's your definition of radically
open-minded
um is to simultaneously have an opinion
like like let me give you this that you
think it should go
this way yes and then you say to
yourself
how do i know i'm right maybe that's
wrong
is that as good as i can be and then the
capacity to hear
and then challenge so somebody comes up
to you with an idea
and says okay let's do this what do you
think about that to harvest the best
around you but sorting it with your own
mind
so i say to be open-minded and assertive
at the same time
don't give up your assertiveness but to
be curious like am i harvesting the best
because the biggest thing that most
people have their problem
is they get so opinionated that they
can't take in
and the worst problem is the worst
tragedy of man kind
almost any individual is that they're
attached to
opinions that are wrong and they don't
want to have them stress tested
so when you're operatically open-minded
you can say hey man i really think it
should go
this way and then at the same time say
to the smartest people that you know
kick the [ __ ] out of it and try to say
okay now let's see how the stress tests
so that i can then go to the best or how
do i harvest
is going to be very important for you to
get your leverage
okay because you want to go to this
new high level right and you want to do
a lot of things
and in order to do the lot of things
you're going to have to get the most
leverage of other people
but you also want it to be great just
like you want it to be because you've
got a unique ability
with your taste and everything to be
able to make those choices so you know
what's great and what's not great
so in order to go from that you have to
pick the people
who can do that who can deliver you what
you could do
to find people who are as good or better
than you
and then to get that leverage the key is
to try to find out what you're
not good at okay write those things down
that you're not
good at and then you get the people who
are good at those things
and then you get the great leverage
right now i've got a special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week
when you watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of following through that's not
enough but when you write down what time
what place and how you're going to
actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're gonna do it
it jumps to 95 percent that you will
follow through so i want that for you
believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you collect good people get into the
habit of collecting good people
what that means is when you find
somebody who you
you hang out with you spend a little bit
of time with and you feel better about
yourself
you have more energy you're more
inspired you want to go home and do more
work and build a better life
when you're around those people even for
a moment
try to find a way to spend more time
with them
most of the people in our lives
[Music]
they're takers not because they're bad
people or they're they're
they're only intake or mentality they're
just they're in a lot of pain they're
struggling a lot
you're probably ahead of where they are
you're the person who's giving them
the motivation the energy the belief the
hope you're the one who's the most
ambitious person
in your circle and so you're pushing the
people around you to do better
you're that person for other people but
who is that person for you
and chances are you don't have that
person in your life and so maybe you get
it from books or from videos
maybe online communities but you don't
have that person in your life
and that's what we need to start to
cultivate and so when you find somebody
around you even if you haven't spent a
lot of time with them
when you feel them it's super important
to pay attention to the energy
pay attention to the energy when you're
around somebody
and you leave them do you feel better or
worse about yourself
do you have more energy more
vitalization
more hope more inspiration or do you
feel drained
do you feel low energy do you feel
lethargic do you feel like you need a
break
was it too overwhelming and again most
of the people in our lives are the ones
who drain us
because they're in a lot of pain and it
takes us a lot of energy to
to help them or to try to just deal with
them
i look at zanderman as an example in my
community so
zanda man uh is a confidence coach he
is now my co-host on my gaming channel
where we answer people's questions live
and he was one of the first people
inside my mover makers program
and zen just had so much energy when you
hang around with zen
you feel better you feel more energetic
you feel more hopeful you feel more
inspired
and so when i started movement makers
he was one of the first people in and
now before i come on so
like in the 10 to 15 minutes before
movement maker starts
zayn's on playing music says hey zayn
you used to be dj
do you want to do you want to do a
little pre-show
welcome people to movement makers as
they join tell them to turn their
cameras on give them some love give them
some energy
just inject some confidence into people
it's like yeah i'd love to do that
and so he's doing that now and it's a
great value add to the people who are
in the community then i said hey do you
want to do a gaming channel a live
gaming channel with me where you answer
questions
i'm going to play the game you you be my
co-host you bring the questions and
we'll both answer them
because i was having a hard time trying
to read the questions and play the game
at the same time
he's like yeah i'm down to do that and
so now i hang out with zen
i went from scenes and you know every
two weeks inside of movement makers
to four times a week
four times a week when i'm answering
questions on the gaming channel
and so i'm trying to find a way to spend
more time with zane because i love the
energy
i love how i feel afterwards and i love
the
value that it also brings the community
and the people watching
so i really want you to start to think
about for your own life who are the
people around you
who make you feel more hopeful more
inspired more positive more empowered
more
more positive like who are those people
and
they may not be people who you're
hanging out with a lot right
if i look at zan the man i was only
seeing him
every two weeks in a group setting
it was in a group with there's lots of
people in there zan was one of the
people
so it's not like i was talking to him
for two hours every two weeks right had
minimal exposure
every two weeks in a group setting but i
singled him out it's like
i like that guy i want to find a way to
spend more time with that guy i want to
do something more
with that guy and he could have said no
to hosting or to djing
but he said yes to both and so there's
probably people who are in your
community somewhere
who you've spent some amount of time
with
that i want you to rack your brain
they're not going to be your closest
friends probably
if you do have that as your closest
friend holy cow are you blessed
uh and and be grateful and tell that
friend thank you so much
but if you don't have that person then
think about over the past six months
who has been somebody who you've met
you've hung out with
in an online setting and how can you
spend more time with them
[Music]
if you want even more insight into how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there your real work
is to figure out where
your power base is i tell the students
you know
you may have to take a job or two you
got to eat